Downing Street there's our political
editor beth rigby and you've been got
some more information Beth what a year
yes stomach just to give you a bit of a
timeline of what happened this afternoon
into the press conference the Prime
Minister still leading the government
Dominic Robb very clear about it as I
understand it after that press
conference things did develop quite
quickly the Prime Minister did have
breathing difficulties and he was given
oxygen before he went into that IC unit
after that press conference so sometime
between 6:00 and 7:00 p.m. after the
press conference wrapped up he was
admitted at 7:00 p.m. so the Prime
Minister did suffer from breathing
difficulties I should make it very clear
that he is not on a ventilator he was
conscious when he went into the
intensive care unit if you are put onto
an event alator
you are unconscious so he's not on a
ventilator but it's rather he's in that
unit and the ventilator is there should
his condition worsen and should he need
that support but he was given some help
breathing he was given oxygen before he
went into the intensive care units
afternoon and bath on that on the
politics on leadership as Adam was
saying there with them Parliament's in
recess the Prime Minister in intensive
care
what is the sense about direction about
ER as the phrases now hand or hands on
the rudder I mean the Prime Minister's
just gone into intensive care tonight I
imagined that the whole country all
parties will rally around him and his
government he has formally given his
first Secretary of State
Dominic Rob power to deputize for him he
made that phone call before he went into
the intensive care unit and mr. Rob is
now taking the day to say decisions for
the government while Boris Johnson is in
intensive care and I think we should
really just take this day at a time at
the moment the prime minister in
intensive care and mr. Rob is doing the
day-to-day response
the coronavirus crisis and he will take
decisions as and when it's necessary on
behalf of the Prime Minister